hi
i'm scott box and today i'm going to
talk about data compression
so data compression is very very general
and you can plug it into a lot of other
things
people tend to sort of treat it as just
a magical thing
that you use but it works so well that
you don't necessarily
think about how it necessarily works but
if you understand a little bit about the
fundamental algorithms that it uses you
can employ it much more effectively
and so you tend to see it used a lot in
things like
content encoding gzip where you can pass
data through in an http connection and
gzip it and then
transparently that reduces the bandwidth
quite a bit for
any web traffic or likewise on windows
you can select a bunch of files and say
send to a compressed folder and
that way you can just pass around a
single file rather than having to
deal with coordinating a whole file tree
or anything like that
and likewise there's tarballs on unix
and
also compression is very important for
multimedia encoding
so that that way you can do streaming
audio streaming video and it uses only a
tiny fraction of the bandwidth that it
would use otherwise
and nowadays when people design new
functionality it's worth
considering what data compression can do
in it and and take advantage of that
and i read a good blog post where the
author
craigan's attacker talked about how in
the curses system on unix
it does a lot of complicated analysis to
figure out how to take
the current screen and then a change
that you want to make on on the text
console and diff that and then actually
send as little data as possible to
update the screen
because if it's being used over a slow
telenet connection or something like
that it could get very laggy
but his argument is that most of that
effort was wasted because they could
have just passed
the the first screen and then the new
screen and then passed it through gzip
and let it do that and in a lot of cases
it would actually do that more
effectively
than the analysis that they try to do by
hand and
similarly i've seen a lot of programs
now that
like their their saved file format is
actually
something that looks like binary data
but it's just compressed
and if you unzip it it's either a flat
text file or it's
xml or something and then that way you
get the best of both worlds because you
can see
all of the actual data for it in a human
readable way but you don't have to deal
with the size
that adds for it but fundamentally what
is data compression
a data compression is a way to
automatically detect and reduce
duplication in arbitrary data
essentially
it's a form of machine learning it's
attempting to learn about the structure
of data
possibly on the fly as it's streaming in
and then restructure it so that it can
be smaller somehow
you have here's a couple strings one of
which doesn't really have any clear
pattern to it
and the other has a very obvious pattern
and there's a term in information theory
called kamagura of complexity
which represents the smallest possible
way that you could describe
a given a bit of information and in the
case on the left you pretty much
have to pass the string through exactly
as it is because there's not an obvious
way to represent that in a smaller form
whereas in the one on the right it's
just a b
a b a b a b uh and very obviously you
could just say repeat a b
eight times and that sort of description
ends up being a lot smaller
there are two main flavors of
compression
and i'm mostly going to talk about
lossless data compression in this talk
there will be some content about lossy
compression at the end
but i'm a lot more familiar with
lossless compression
and um for lossless compression there's
gzip and
zip files which are used a great deal
there's also gif images
and many many other things and there's
also lossy compression
which is particularly common in
multimedia data formats
like in jpegs mp3 files and so on
but it's also worth noting here that gif
images
tend to use a lossless compression too
and there's some reasons for that
in in that case usually it's not like
photographic images that can be blurred
together and such it's more like
diagrams with very crisp edges to them
and so lossless methods are very
effective there
and here are a bunch of lossless
algorithms that i'm going to cover
starting out with some very simple ones
so first off there's run length coding
this is really really easy to implement
and probably everybody has independently
invented it at some point or another
including like
office pets um so you have
a b b b b c and so on and
to do run length coding on this to start
out you'd say
a okay we have an a pass that out as is
now we have five b's and instead of
passing those through exactly as they
are put a count in there
and then a c and then 10 ds and then an
e
now the other thing is there's multiple
ways of representing that sort of data
you can have most of the data be exactly
as it is and then put a special marker
to indicate that something
is going to have a count applied to it
or something like that
or you can put a count on everything or
or represent that at
a bit in byte level and various other
ways and this is an implementation
detail
that isn't necessarily a part of any of
the algorithms but it's something that
often matters a great deal in practice
and next there's a delta coding
so if you had a range of integers like
this
typically fairly large numbers um but
these are sorted
and the gaps between them are fairly
small this could be like
integer primary keys from a database
query or something
it's often a lot more effective to just
store
the base number and then represent the
diff the distances between them
and then there's ways of doing variable
bit coding
for numbers so that you don't have to
have something take up say
always 16 bits or something like that
there's a gamma coding there's a couple
other things like that
where if on average most of your numbers
will fit in four bits you can shrink
those down quite a bit
but um that's outside the scope of this
talk
and another thing with delta coding and
many other compression algorithms
is that this works very well when you
have a sequence of numbers with small
gaps between them but every once in a
while you'll have a big jump
and so you need to have a special way
of encoding that you're setting a new
base number that they're all relative to
or something like that
it's it's very characteristic of data
compression to have
data that you're passing through and
metadata about it and they're both going
out through the same channel so you have
to be very careful about how you
differentiate those
and another one called huffman coding
is a little bit more complicated
but still that dates back to the early
50s and that's
really a fundamental sort of thing it's
a way of
instead of representing data in a
typical character set like ascii
or utf-8 or something coming up with a
custom bit encoding for data that is
based on
the statistical properties of the data
itself and a good example of this
is morse code which was designed for
english to come up with a very short way
of representing letters
and so very common letters have a really
really short representation like e
or t which are just a dot or a dash
whereas
letters that are very very infrequent in
english text can have a longer pattern
for them
and morse code is not exactly the same
here because morse code is actually
trinary
you can say dot dash or pause time is an
element in it
and in a bit stream that's not
necessarily the case
but but conceptually it's very similar
and the way that you implement that is
you take whatever data you want to
compress
break it into tokens and tokens in this
case could be individual bytes
it could be all of the words that occur
in a document it could be
just any sort of atomic unit and what
that is
is very flexible and then you sort them
by frequency
and then you pick two of the elements
or two of the elements that have the
lowest count
and then merge them into into a tree
that has one node above them that
goes down to them and then you keep
doing this merging together
items with the lowest counts or nodes
that have lower sum
counts and gradually build up an
unbalanced binary tree and i'll show a
diagram for that in a moment
and this is really good because it
adapts to the characteristics of your
particular data so if you have something
with
a typical distribution to to normal
english text
like the phrase the captain here which
has t's and e's and h's and
some other fairly common letters that
that might not be that different from a
normal encoding
but if you have something that inverts
that distribution like the second line
there
which is uh syzygy of zephyrs
that has a lot of z's and y's and so if
you tried to do that in morse code it
wouldn't be very good and
so it can automatically adapt to that
sort of thing and and likewise humorless
leaflet
homulus lupulus there in which every
other letter is a u
it can pick up on that also so what this
looks like in practice
is uh i've color-coded these because you
might not be able to read them
but there are three nodes that have a
count of one which are
n i and c this is for the phrase the cat
and the hat
and then there's one that has two for
the letter a
and then there are three h's and then
there are four
uh t's and four spaces which i've
represented with underscores here just
to make it easier to see so we grab the
two nodes
with lower counts and there are actually
three of them here
you can pick any of them it doesn't
really matter as long as you have a
deterministic way of
breaking ties so you merge those and now
there's a node that has two
and then you merge it you merge
another pair that has the lowest counts
which in this case
uh could be the other remaining one node
and one with a count of two
that could be either the two node that
was just created or the letter there
with a count of two
and then you keep merging keep merging
and then you get to the point here
there's a bit of a jump where the space
on the far right jumps up to the left
and then you merge one more time and
everything is contained in a nice little
tree
and then the the nice thing with this
sort of tree
is that if you swap the arrows in the
other direction you can also use this as
a way of decoding arbitrary bit patterns
to those letters
you can see the table on the upper right
there t and h
and space have a coding where they're
all representable in two bits
whereas the other letters which are
deeper down in the tree can be
represented in four bits
but since on average those occur quite a
bit less frequently
the overall document will be compressed
quite a bit better
and also because this is a complete tree
traversal there's no ambiguity about
which nodes you're ending up in
so you don't have to worry about
breaking the data into byte boundaries
and saying i know where
this is the end of one letter in the
beginning of another letter just anytime
you end up at a terminal node
you add that to the output stream and
then continue
one downside with huffman coding though
is that this tree needs to be output
with the data
so that if you have a very very small
amount of data
just including that tree itself might
actually end up increasing the overall
size
so there are also some more
sophisticated
algorithms than that and i'm going to
go next to lz77
which is commonly referred to as sliding
window compression
it's named after it's named after the
two people who invented it who were
jacob ziv and abraham limple
in 1977 and this is called sliding
window compression because it has
a buffer referred to as the sliding
window for recent
content that is passed through it and
then as
content goes through it it either
outputs data literally
or it includes back references to recent
things that have occurred
so that if you have something that is
being put through it and then has
occurred several times in the last 32
kilobytes of data or something it can
just
put a back reference to that and it can
represent that in a much smaller way
than
putting the whole string in there again
so here's another string with some
repetition in it
and uh stepping through this
first off it begins with a b and c those
don't
appear in the buffer yet because this is
the very start of the string we haven't
done anything
so those just get put out as literal
characters
and then there's abc again but we just
saw that
so instead of including that 24 bits
for those three characters we can just
put in a back reference that says go
back three characters and then grab the
next three characters from that point in
the stream
and that can typically be represented in
say 11 bits
maybe 10 maybe nine or eight depending
on how big that buffer is
and that's just a couple bits
representing the offset
negative into that buffer from where the
output currently is
and then the length for the number of
characters to pull out
so then next we have a d which hasn't
appeared yet
so that goes out literally and then we
have abcd
which we just saw and so we can include
a back reference to that again
and then efgh and then now we run into
abc
abc which this could be represented a
couple different
ways um we could include the abc that
begins this string
twice but lz77 is greedy and will always
try
to take the largest match that it can
because usually
from a compression standpoint that's the
best thing to do
and so it'll run all the way back to the
beginning of the string and then take
those six characters that occur there
and if there is um if that string has
occurred
many many times it doesn't really matter
which of those in particular it would
refer to
typically it will grab either the most
recent occurrence or the oldest
occurrence that's still in the buffer
just depending on how
the implementation tends to lean either
oldest or newest but it doesn't really
matter
and then the hij at the end of that
string gets put out literally because
that hasn't occurred at all elsewhere
also since the recent output is used to
store
the patterns it doesn't need to include
any sort of encoding tree like the
huffman method or anything else like
that
it's just the buffer that it's doing its
temporary work in to do the
decompression is also
all of the working space it needs to
store those patterns
which is a really useful property
because it means you have a very
fine-grained control about how much
working space it needs
and also one other example since it's
international talk like a pirate day
a back reference uh can also work kind
of like a train that's laying down its
own tracks as it's rolling along
because it's going into that output
buffer not
the compressed data which means that in
a string like this
it would output the r the a literally
and then the r
and then i could say back up one
character and grab the next nine
characters
and when it's decompressing that works
perfectly fine because that output has
been expanded and is available to refer
to
but this is really handy because uh
first of all you get run length coding
for free
and second of all if you have very
sparse data like bitmap
images or something like that this is
really effective
and so but that's just something that
falls out of the way that it's typically
implemented
so the next method i'm going to talk
about lz78
commonly called dictionary compression
this was invented by the same people the
following year
um and in this case instead of having a
sliding window that you're looking for
repetitions in you have a table of
patterns
that you're using as substitutions and
it starts out
empty and you look at the next byte of
output
and say hey have we seen that pattern
before and if so then
include a reference to it and as many of
the characters following it as you can
grab
otherwise create a new pattern starting
with that byte
and then after that's gone on for a bit
you have a table of a couple short
patterns
but as you make a substitution you
create a new pattern
that refers back to it and so the
patterns that are useful
keep growing and so you you end up with
the patterns that have been
most useful for this particular data set
getting very long
as as long as they are still useful this
is also a persistent data structure
although it wasn't really something that
was defined in those terms back then
because the table starts with a single
character
and then that's immutable but it counts
as another character onto it
it's it's like a reversed list and so
that way
any of the ways in which that grows it
can just
add on one more index and say okay and
then continue with this other pattern
and then the other thing is that when
the dictionary is too full
it just throws the whole thing out and
starts over
and this is a very effective way of
adapting the patterns that are being
used to recent context
most data compression algorithms try to
use a
property of locality because say in a
text document you might have a phrase
that comes up a lot
and then in the next chapter of a book
you don't hear about that anymore
and so adapting to that sort of thing
tends to make compression more effective
it also means that it can run in
constant space because you have a buffer
that you're filling up with patterns
and then emptying and you can just keep
reusing that buffer
and also this dictionary doesn't need to
be transferred either because it's being
built up on the fly both on the
compression and decompression sides
so many many things that are in common
use are just
slight variants on lz77 or lz78
because in the in the most general case
they're
really really effective but often
they're combined with huffman coding or
there's some other little changes to how
they're implemented that make them more
effective
and a good example of that is lzss uh
lempulziv
store zamanski which is based off of the
sliding window technique
um and this this is also a pattern that
you'll see a lot where there's lz
something compression which is uh level
ziv and then
the people who implemented some novel
variant of it just tack their names on
the end
so like if you if you go to wikipedia
there's a category node that says lz
400 different variants and but most of
them
you can just say oh is this based on
dictionary compression or sliding window
compression
oh okay how do they vary on that and so
it's pretty easy to pick up on them
so with lz ss
in the lz 77 method it will always take
substitutions
even if it's adding a substitution that
takes up
more space than just including the data
literally it's it's greedy in that way
but the point of actually breaking even
tends to be more substituting
two maybe three bytes it depends on a
couple things
and also the original method used a
whole byte marker
to indicate whether it was literal text
or
something that represented a back
reference and there's absolutely no
need for that so instead this uses a
single bit
and then it does all of the necessary
bit shifting and buffering and all of
that stuff
um i i think that lempel and cf were
more thinking about this from a
mathematical standpoint and not really
like a data structure
bit packing kind of standpoint which
this
is perfectly fine
and then another variant is lemplesive
welch which is based off of the
dictionary methods
the most significant difference there is
that it starts with a smart
default dictionary that has all
individual bytes in it and a couple
other patterns
and that means that since it knows from
the get go that
this code represents just the letter e
or the at sign or something like that it
doesn't need to take any space for those
in the table
so it's able to do a bit more patterns
in the same amount of space that way
which means it can compress more
effectively
and another reason that lzw is a good
example
is it was at the heart of a really nasty
patent situation
if any of you remember the burn all
gifts thing
the the gif image format has lzw
designed into it as part of the standard
but lcw was actually patented at the
time
and you had to get a license to use it
which
conflicted really badly with how it was
becoming a very ubiquitous image file
format
so among other things the the ping image
file format came out of trying to design
one that
didn't have those sort of ip
restrictions
and then that patent has been expired
for a while but there's a lot of other
compression methods that
are patented and i'm just not even going
to bring them up
because you really can't do anything
with them
and another one is deflate which
is used in gzip and it was also used in
pkzip
on windows and i believe it's used in
the standard zip file format for
compression on windows
and so if you uh if you use the z-lib
library to do data compression and you
don't
specify a particular algorithm it'll
default to this it'll default to having
like a 64 kilobyte hash table
in memory that it uses with character
trigrams
three consecutive characters to do
dispatch to try to find patterns faster
and it has a special block header that
says for this next data passing through
do we want to use helpmancoding
do we want to use lcss or do we want to
use both of them in combination one than
the other
or some content if it's already been
compressed like if it's
video data that's been encoded some way
or something then it can also just
pass that data through without doing
anything to it
because if you take a bunch of data and
then you have to put
one bit marker on every single byte
saying oh literally this literally this
literally this
then it just expands it by 1 8 and
there's no point in doing that
and then finally for the lossless
compression i'm going to talk about the
boro's wheeler transform
but so besides trying to search for
repeated patterns
you can also pre-process data to make it
sort better
or to make it compress better
and a particularly obvious
transformation is
if you sorted data it would be a lot
easier to compress well because you'd
have long runs of the same characters
and uh there's a guy who made a version
of the king james bible that has been
fully
sorted letter by letter
and so there's just can you see that
okay okay cool
and so there's just pages and pages of
ease and stuff and obviously
that would compress a lot better than if
you were trying to work with that with
all the words in their normal order
but the problem with sorting like that
is that it's a one-way process
you can't sort something and then
compress it and then magically put
everything
else back in the original order now if
only there was
one weird trick you could do to undo the
sword
now there's this transformation called
the burrows wheeler transform
which is sort of partially sorting but
in a particular
unusual way that you're able to undo and
this has the effect
that if you have a lot of very localized
patterns like
th in english is a good one you have the
you have there you have this
that stuff like that it will tend to
group together
so that you'll get a lot of runs of ts
and h's adjacent to each other and so
the the
output from that transformation will
tend to compress more effectively
and um if you've ever used i believe
it's actually called bzip2
now the b there stands for the burroughs
wheeler transform
that's what distinguishes that and
that's why it's often more effective at
compressing
certain kinds of data so the way that
this works
um usually this is done in large blocks
but i'm
trying to stick with what you can
actually see on a slide so
i just picked the word repetition here
now if you add a starting marker to this
and then take all of the single
character rotations of that
so you see there's repetition and then
you drop the first character and put it
at the end of the line
and each line is is slided slid over
by one bite now if you do that
and then you sort those lines
lexicographically
so now uh the start one is still at the
beginning but all of the other lines
have been rearranged
so you see it goes e e i i n
and then t is at the end because
alphabetically that's the last line to
appear there
and if you just take that last column
even in this small example you can see
that two of the t's wound up together
because repetition is repetitive
now you can take that last column of
that matrix
and compress that but you can also undo
that transformation and the way that you
do that is
if you if you save that last column and
then sort it again
and then take that column and tack that
onto the front of it
in the next to last column and then
sort that and then add the column again
to it
and then just keep ticking through that
you can see the original string
start to emerge there
and then you sort it one last time and
because there's a special start marker
on it you know which of those rotations
is the original string
and there we go
and the other funny thing with this is
the people who discovered this
had no idea what to do with it
they're just like wow it's amazing that
this works and it never fails to amaze
me
that this works um but it was over
10 years before they realized oh this
would actually be really useful for data
compression
and until then i don't know if they just
like
impressed people with it at parties or
something like that
um but also uh actual implementations of
this
don't use like a big matrix of
characters they use one array with a
bunch of offsets in it
but conceptually it's a lot easier to
think of it as working that way
but since it might be running like a 64
kilobyte block or something you wouldn't
want to square the size of that in
memory because that would
take up a dreadful amount of space and
speaking of memory so recently i was
working on an embedded project
and i needed data compression for that
and uh before i get into that how many
of you have done any embedded work or
like
cool or arduinos stuff like that
okay uh keep your hands up how many of
you have ever run gzip on an arduino
yeah exactly gzip assumes a minimum of
64k of memory for its hash table and
that's just
completely out of the question and a lot
of embedded projects you might have
you know a few kilobytes of ram maybe
512 bytes
depending on what kind of chip you're on
and also a lot of embedded projects are
hard real-time systems
so you might not have an os at all or
you may have
a real-time os which is just barely a
scheduler and a couple ipc
primitives and so if you have a lot of
data you don't want to
run through compressing or decompressing
that all in one blocking step
because at that point either the car has
exploded or
the usb bus has decided that you're not
actually connected anymore because
you're not responding to the keep alive
packet once every millisecond
or that sort of thing or if you're like
parsing radio data as it's streaming in
you'll completely fall out of sync with
it
so i looked around for options for data
compression that would actually work in
an embedded system
and came up empty-handed there were a
couple
decompression in particular that were
available but some of them had bad
licenses
some of them used more space than i
actually was able to use
most of them worked in one pass and i
didn't really see anything that did
compression on an embedded system
which is important because you often
have like
very repetitive sensor data that you're
reading periodically
and you mostly care about when it
changes but you want to record
everything that you can
and then do processing on it later and
if you can collapse a lot of very
similar data together
you can do a lot more with the tiny tiny
bit of space that you have
so i made an implementation of lzss
which i called heat shrink
which is the the sliding window
technique
and this is designed so that it scales
way way way down and it can do real
useful data decompression in under 50
bytes of memory
and if you want to do compression on the
embedded system it takes about 100 bytes
if you have more memory than that it can
take advantage of it and compress more
effectively
but that's that's the bare minimum to
get something useful out of it
and and most systems can at least manage
that and it doesn't take a whole lot of
rom space either
the code is usually under a kilobyte
when it's compiled
and that's under a bsd style license
i actually had to find a particular bsd
variant license
that didn't have weird considerations
for when stuff was distributed only as
hardware which is
something that i hadn't really thought
of evaluating licenses but turns out to
be really important
so the way that i implement oh and i
chose lzss
because the output buffer is also the
working set
for the decompression patterns which
means that it can get by with a much
smaller amount of space
than uh other things that need temporary
data structures for all
for like a huffman tree or something
like that while they're working
so the way that i implemented this was
by
creating a big formal state machine for
it
where i was able to represent all the
transitions and ensure that if
i had to suspend and resume on
individual bits of i o
because this is being co-routine with
other stuff that's going on
then i could be sure to keep the
information that i needed and then be
able to restore that later on to
continue where i left off
and so the api for this uh my favorite
way of describing it is
something where you dump in data and
then you turn the crank and then you
just keep turning the crank until
nothing more comes out
and then you dump in more data and keep
turning and so on and so on
and once you're done you tell it that
you aren't that you aren't going to have
any more input
and then keep turning the crank until
you reach the end of the output stream
and then tear the whole thing down
and modeling this as a state machine
helped shake out a lot of edge cases
so the the blue transitions here are
where the user of the library
is inputting data into it and the red
transitions are where it is
sending output into an output buffer
that the user is supplied
and then there are also many states that
actually have red
and blue arcs on them
and that way if if it's expanding a very
very large pattern
it can expand it step by step even if
there's a very small buffer that that's
going into it'll fill it up
say that it's done you copy that
somewhere else or do whatever with it
and then after that you
call it again and then it fills up the
buffer again and you just incrementally
step through all of the output
and um also by controlling the size of
these buffers
you can also configure how much work it
does in a single step
so if you have very very hard real-time
guarantees and you have to do all of
your processing and say
200 microseconds or something per step
that's that's an option
and i chose the decompression state
machine for this because
most of the complexity is in the
compression and that will not fit on one
slide
but the other thing i like about this
diagram is that it actually has
a bug in it and it's the first thing
that jumps out at me now
but um when i originally made the
library the the size of the offset
into the sliding window was always eight
bits or less
so that was one byte that i could buffer
inside the data structure for it
accumulate the bits for it and then when
it was done move on
and just before i released the library i
increased that
because sometimes it's useful to have
say
a four kilobyte buffer or something and
that's what 12 bits
so that way you might be reading like a
length counter out of
the bit stream but then that means that
there's actually more than one bite
involved there
and i didn't want to increase the size
of the accumulator because of some
alignment issues and stuff and it would
have wound up taking a lot more space
all just like ugly c details but so
uh what i had to do was take this state
here
where if it was accumulating 12 bits
from
the input stream and it got five of them
and then suspended and then resumed it
would throw those away
um it wouldn't retain them properly so i
had to take that step and split it in
half
to getting the upper couple bits if if
the size was defined to be that large
and then accumulate the lower bits
and then that worked fine so
here's a demo of heat shrink running on
a big block of text
this is a software license agreement and
like all software license agreements it
says that you should not use it to
design manufacture or produce nuclear
missiles
chemical or biological weapons
any of you want to guess what this is
the license for
i'm sorry yeah itunes good guess
so i passed this through heat shrink
and it goes from that to that
and each one of those pound signs there
is 11 bits
rather than an 8 bit character this is
assuming an ascii
encoding for that and i specifically
chose
a software license because if you look
at some of the patterns that it picks up
on
it's very clear that this is in legalese
this this can be like a nice
way of fingerprinting a document and
seeing what the significant phrases are
in it
even if you don't actually care about
reducing the size of it and that's a
pretty cheap operation
so it noticed that the big cumbersome
phrase
the licensed application if it could
represent that in a couple bits
there was a really major size savings
and likewise united states law
without limitation though and may not be
and
in the case of if out limitation the
it's dropping the leading w
i assume because sometimes it's
uppercase sometimes it's lowercase
um but it also picked up
on some kind of counter-intuitive
substitutions
like chun actional and edini
but when lzs has a really really big
buffer to dip into it can just
pick up on a lot of stuff like that so
also there's lossy compression which is
a lot more data specific
lossless compression has to work in the
general case but lossy compression
assumes that you're working with a
certain kind of image data or audio data
or something like that
and it's it's really a kind of smart
degradation of that content where it can
throw away details that the human eye
might not pick up on or
most people won't be able to hear and
there's like a slider there
for if you don't mind if the quality of
it starts to get low but you need it to
be really really small you can start
cutting a little deeper
and so i have an example here where i
have this
image three times on the left there's
the original image
in the middle i've decreased the quality
of it so it's actually half the file
size it goes from 51k to 27k
but you can't really tell a difference
unless you look at it really close and
some details like the edges or the
reflections in the glass or the shadows
or the wood grain
tend to show that more but then i
have the size of that one more time and
it goes from 27 to 14k
and then that gets really pixely because
the way that
jpeg compression works um the the
primary way that it works is breaking an
image
into an 8x8 pixel grid and getting the
average color
and then applying a bunch of a certain
number of
gradients over that that then add other
details onto it and they're translucent
and the way that those overlap
ends up defining most of the detail in
the image
so in closing i've talked about why data
compression matters
how to design uh data so that it can be
compressed more effectively
uh talked about lossless compression
algorithms and then there's the case
study of heat shrink
and the example lossy compression
so if you want to learn more about this
here are two books that i particularly
like
managing gigabytes and information
theory inference and learning algorithms
the letter which also has a bunch of
machine learning and some other topics
in it
and there's certainly overlap there and
there's a free pdf of that on the
author's site if you're interested
and also i work for a really cool
transparent company in michigan
and if you want to know if you know
anyone who wants to do cool work for a
small company we're hiring at our
detroit and our offices
so i have a couple minutes for questions
i think
anybody yes
um
okay uh to to try to summarize that for
the people who can't hear you
uh he he he said that if you you
if you're doing uh compression on a
known data type you can pre-compute but
a good table of substitutions would be
and then build that into your
application and not need to represent
that explicitly in the data stream
and and that's a case where you know a
lot more about your problem domain
than just a very very general
compression algorithm
and there's a certain point where that
turns into designing a binary
coding for your data format by hand but
um
it's it's good to know that tools like
zlib can also automate a lot of that
work
uh anybody else in the back
that that what i don't know
i okay okay yeah and and i i couldn't
fit lcma into this talk i kind of type
for time as is so
yeah there's there's a bunch of other
algorithms i mostly focused on those
particular ones because of the ones that
i'm most familiar with but i was also
looking at ones that tended to scale
down
rather than up there's some some
interesting stuff that google and a
couple other really large companies are
adding to their infrastructure that make
uh very different trade-offs for like if
you have a lot of memory and want
maximal efficiency of the compression
that's kind of the opposite of the
problem that i have so
i didn't really go into that anybody
else yes
well oh the question was
how do you weigh the benefits of these
different algorithms against each other
and decide what's most suitable for your
application
you you could if you have a really solid
intuition about how they work
you can think about how that might
impact your data but really the easiest
thing to do
is just to find what you consider
representative data and then do a bunch
of experiments in benchmarking and see
and and then maybe re-evaluate that on a
periodic basis
if the character of your data starts to
change but it's it's easiest to just run
it and measure it's not something that
you need really elaborate infrastructure
for
anybody else yes
that's that's another talk that would be
that would be a talk that i would love
to attend but that's another talk
okay anybody else yes
not at the moment i would love to talk
with you afterward though if
if you're interested in that space so
okay anybody else
on the book slide sure
[Music]
and like i said the one on the right
there there's a free pdf of it on the
author's site
and the one on the left is not free but
well well worth it
so okay uh one final question because it
looks like i'm getting out of time
okay thanks